Trump has followed in noble history of
attracting attention using techniques
that other totalitarian leaders used
before him and particularly the fascists
now I'm not saying those are the views
of Trump but I'm saying he does use the
same methods and one of the keys this is
something that Adolf Hitler in
particular understood is that the most
compelling way to fire up your audience
is to speak to their unconscious fears
and hatreds and give voice to them in a
way and that seems to really in terms of
attention just grab people in this very
intense way so if you study carefully
the the rise of the Third Reich it is
fascinating how well the speakers of the
Third Reich targeted unconscious
unspoken but truly present fears hatreds
powerful emotions you know far beyond of
the thinking mind and you know I think
that it can be those techniques whether
or not you're a Nazi or Hitler or
whatever you are are effective for any
one who wants to captivate their
audience and inspire an angry rally and
so I think that you know there's some
similarities one of the things I also
think is very interesting about the rise
you know Trump's success in the
particular ethnic primary campaign he's
obviously a master attention merchant
and mastered getting people to just want
to see what he does next and you know we
have a private media you know we don't
have a state media nonetheless there has
been for the last year the phenomenon
where you turn on the television or you
turn on any website and there's Trump's
face you know it as time reminded me of
the heights of some of the totalitarian
schemes are like North Korea
we're everywhere you look there is great
leader or in China during the 60s
everywhere you look there's now you know
everywhere you look you could not get
away from this and I think you know
Trump may come to lose this election but
i think the rise has been terrifying the
use of the private media to effectively
propagandize and get millions of dollars
in what has been effectively free
coverage has been something to learn
from and you know every republic is
always in some danger of tipping over
into an authoritarian regime and usually
is control the media that begins that
process